foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
that's what I'll give you to decide your
faith
[Music]
what did you do back home
government work I'm retired
because of these people I'm beginning to
understand real people and I'm starting
to believe
this is where I'm supposed to be
thank you
what happens here happens in many times
the mafia there's like cancer
no cue
I should say out of other people's
business whatever it is you and your
friends do do it somewhere else you
warning me I'm preparing is that a Timex
no it's a book that's the median nerve
but I'm compressed
that's a level three you don't want it
to go to a level four
seem like a man who understands violence
you can't take that from me
I can take anything I want
police found multiple dead bodies on
that farm in Sicily do you kill him
[Music]
nine seconds
do I look like a killer
[Music]
I am honored to introduce to you the
creator of The Hunger Games themselves
Dean casca High bottom
I have summoned you all here for the
10th Annual reaping ceremony in which we
choose two children from each district
to fight to the death in The Hunger
Games from District 12 Lucy gray bear
[Music]
there has been a change this year as a
mentor Mr snow Your Role is to turn
these children into spectacles not
survivors
what does my mentor do besides bring me
roses I do my best to take care of you
you really want to take care of me in
that Arena
you start by thinking I can actually win
I'm lucky flickerman first ever host of
The Hunger Games
[Music]
what happens in there
filled with the terror becoming prey
see how quickly we become predator
see how quickly civilization disappears
foreign
there's a natural goodness built into us
all
across that line into evil
or not
you hear that boy
it's the sound of snow
falling
[Music]
how wonderful that we all get to be here
for someone's final performance
everything is about winning
oh
it's the things we love most
Try Us
you know we don't really be there if
Roman wasn't driving Fort Knox on wheels
see me shining baby
we're locked inside it's a trap that's
the bomb all right dorks what are we
blowing up what the Vatican
you guys are going to hell
the great Dom Toretto if you never would
have gotten behind that wheel
and never be the man I am today
and now I'm the man that's going to
break your family
Peace by peace the devil's coming
boom
dummy I knew you would come for me well
how about we all just start shooting
each other
let's dig some Graves
you are not to be trusted are you in on
my Christmas list either
calvary's here
we need weapons and cars
do you like surprises I adore them
I'd stay down if I was you you'll need
to hit me harder for that
the game's over down you lose
your last ride
[__]
you might want to buckle up
[Applause]
yeah foreign
[Music]
has stayed hidden on Earth
the darkness has found us again prime
this is about the fate of all living
things
Unicron is coming
thank you
[Music]
Becca Oh I thought we were boys
caught a human here I'm nobody I ain't
even seen nothing I'm not even seeing
anything right now
stop
this is not our war
Optimus we must trust each other to
protect the home we all share
how big can this guy be uh he eats
planets so like way bigger than a planet
in the end
everything you cared for
maybe there's another way to save our
home
you've never faced anything like this
let them come
on
[Music]
y'all know it take the wheel
thank you
I lost my parents
that pain
[Music]
made me who I am
I spent a lifetime trying to right the
wrongs of the past
as if fighting crime would bring my
parents back
you actually did it
I can't imagine what you've been through
you lost both parents in one day very
I completely broke the universe
if you look back and changed the path
this world must die
you change the future
do you know what the symbol stands for
means hope right
I will help you if I thought
you want to get nuts
let's get nuts
[Music]
I have to undo what I did
hey scars
make us who we are I'm about to go back
and fix them
no that's your tragedy to find you
oh
no matter what we do
We're not gonna be able to fix this no
body died
[Music]
you're strapped to your parachutes Hey
where's yours
oh
my God
imagine a place
where wishes come true
where your heart's desire can become a
reality
what if I told you that place
is what you have to do is give your wish
to me
I wish
[Music]
what was that
what were you doing don't you don't need
that
[Music]
it didn't work when does the magic
happen huh
I'm talking I am talking who knew my
voice would be this low
[Music]
I'm sure there will be challenges
please
your daughter
the park
ing attention just for a second
[Applause]
work think I'm ready for Duty do you
feel ready I think it's the only thing
keep missing
what's the call I'm calling to reporter
bank robbery is this crime currently in
progress today see that guy on the bench
do you have a lighter I guess
it's very hot today
it's like a furnace
a second furnace
there's a safe deposit box
[Music]
but I'm the wrong man
where is she
I know you called the tip in on the bad
guys
the hell are you what makes totals
strangers love an elaborate bank heist
are you familiar with the concept of
hypnotics hypnotics
hypnotics have the ability to influence
the brain sound
voice you know what blocking eyes
if not excused them to make you see a
version of the world that doesn't exist
foreign
[Music]
goodbye
hypnotics makes everything that you see
and do
perfectly normal
we're the Guardians of the Galaxy all
the love you feel romantic sexual no no
I don't no
all the laughs
try again
as led to this that is sad
you know what's sad people on Earth die
when they're like 50. are you about to
die I'm not 50.
safe
so what should we do next start your
summer something good something bad with
a happy ending
knock it off what you got issues quill
oh come on
into the Galaxy vol 3 only in Peters May
5th tickets on sale now
are you ready we're ready to forget the
further once and for all
[Music]
my brain just been foggy past few years
all I ever wanted was to be a good dad
adulting
[Music]
did you ever try and get help I'm just
trying to push through
[Music]
you drive Dalton to college you still
have a few weeks before your students
show up right just an idea to reconnect
I know it's been tough with you too
oh
the balance of light and dark is what
we're after you're an art school I take
it yeah you go here too yes
draw an experience that defines you when
I was 10.
it's in a coma
but I don't even remember being sick
sink deep into your memory and let's see
what life can find
oh
[Music]
I think these drawings could be Clues
from my past
you don't know and I was too scared to
tell you the truth our family has been
keeping secrets they suppressed our
memories but I can still feel something
following us there's only one way to
find out
I'll give you
I feel like I'm getting closer to
something
closer to me
when you awaken the Dead the further you
travel the riskier your journey will
become
[Music]
she was a [__] father
a woman was found killed in town
[Music]
what are you doing
you never loved me you never loved
anyone in your life
[Music]
years ago you asked me what two men
could do living together on a ranch
I'll answer you now
[Music]
everyone who ever lived here Falls
victim to some tragedy
like her daughter a year ago
my daughter was my whole life
to hear her voice again
I would give all I have
foreign if someone wants to be heard
[Music]
we are here
foreign
we cannot hide from our ghosts
whether they are real or not
[Music]
thank you
when I was younger I joined the military
after I left I met a man named Caldwell
his clients wanted people dead
bad people
murderous rapists corrupt officials
that's where I come in
[Music]
there she is missed you oh God what did
they do to you nothing that's why it's
not fine every time you go away bruises
Cuts
Morgan it's a new job yeah I told you
I'm out it's not that simple it's six
separate contracts and each one pays a
million dollars tell me about it they're
assassins marketing like you
[Applause]
hard to kill me and each other factors
Morgan they were coming for you
whether you accepted or not
this is a game and if you want to live
you have to play try not to reduce the
splendid City to rubble and make any
promises
thank you
for coming now I need to fight to
protect you whatever this is
you think you're a good man don't you
Morgan
and suffer first
somebody's pit us against each other
women to feel the consequences of what
we've done
[Music]
foreign
but let's face it it's a complicated
game guys soccer as you like to call it
is like life next season I think we have
a real shot I'm sorry uh Thomas did
nobody tell you
you're you're fired
good news is you got two options option
one that's where you're currently at or
American Samoa are you serious
we haven't scored one goal in the
history of our country trying to have a
soccer team
scored again humiliation mark my words
things are going to change I got us a
new coach
something to drink whiskey beer wine yep
we got all those which one whiskey beer
and wine
foreign
it's safe to say you have zero Talent OR
understanding of the game
I'm right about this guy what he is
white
coach you got the toughest job on the
island
what we want is just one goal one goal
come on guys we've worked too long and
hard for this you've only been here a
few days
can't work with these guys for them it's
like some sort of game
that's a giant leadership now we're
making some progress
thank you for sending us Mr rongan we've
become quite attached to him it's like
finding a little lost white kid at the
mall and telling him which way to go
okay it's win by two not here it's not
even yoga instructor's in the gym now
well I just noticed you're not getting
enough legs under the shot are you
dehydrated 100 bucks you can't make more
shots let's just do 300. it's not my
dad's money
you ain't never gonna get evaporation
that way bro so I prefer venmo or Zell
but you seem like a cash app guy so
ladies and gentlemen
are you thinking slick huh
it's showing up the course dressed like
a dumbass acting like you can't who you
assumed I couldn't because I'm white
which is incredibly outdated I assumed
you couldn't hoop because you were
dressed like a white girl at Whole Foods
it's really hard to plan for the future
when we're always worried about money
because you're out here living in a
fantasy my 30-day detox program you want
a free sample no I ain't drinking no
boo-boo juice babe it's almost first I'm
gonna go tomorrow I forgot why don't you
just go now it'll be fine don't worry
mommy no I love you
mommy every Hooper I know is entering
that big ass tournament with a winner
get 500 000. I just need somebody who
can play so I can make some money
be joking right 500 000 for one day I
hope yeah yeah yeah we can hustle a few
games together to get the money for the
entry fee I'll find some marks those
short shorts look incredible throw them
off their game yeah the only fast and
we'll clean up you're gonna wear that
trash bag you're gonna wear that fake
ass Richard Simmons outfit
I bet you all got more in common than me
release for me
don't spend any money until we can cover
the feet I should be saying that to you
well I'm good with money so am I so am I
me too me too where where are you bro
just wanted to see if you had superhuman
hearing because of your because my what
thank you you could talk way more trash
out there you have so much material I
can't even touch
like what
never mind oh
tell us where the Love Goes
[Music]
when there are scary things we don't
understand
our minds try to fill in the blanks
Sometimes the best thing to do is to
face it
so this light is going to be completely
solid like it is right now
and gradually it's going to start
flashing until it's totally dark
so you can see that there's nothing to
be afraid of
okay
see that's not so scary is it
just you your sister and me
[Music]
okay
so I'll just in your head
[Music]
oh
Katie there's something in my room
you believe me
don't you
there's no such thing as monsters you
need to grow up
I'm serious Sawyer I need to be alone
infestations
[Music]
for your kids when you're not paying
attention
[Applause]
you have to listen to me okay
I'm listening
sweetheart let me handle
[Music]
then we are with the fact that the
Russians
reality
I don't think that you're some big bad
Mastermind spy kind of thing
[Music]
he made a mistake
have you ever taken anything outside the
NSA facility
foreign
because telling a lie to an FBI agent is
not going to be the right thing
why do I have this job if I'm going to
be helpless
[Music]
you scared the crap out of me I couldn't
resist
tell me about this new school with yours
right now I'm just trying to fit in it's
kind of in my motto ever since I left my
old school Julia you did not leave your
old school you're expelled for being
cruel to another boy
I'm sure your father has told you
stories about when I was a young girl he
says you don't really like to talk about
it I don't
but now I think for your sake I must
[Music]
excuse me oh God what is he doing I saw
this on your desk thanks you're welcome
I didn't even know his name look at this
freak
but we had in common one crucial thing
it's really good for a Jew
we had both seen how much hate people
are capable of one of the children's
missing find them and
hurricane took to be kind we need to
come with me
and dark times
no small things remind us of our
Humanity
I would like to visit New York tonight
sure open your eyes
you're the prettiest person I've ever
met
you forget many things in life
you never forget kindness
because when kindness can cost you your
life
it becomes like a miracle
what do you want to be going to lourd
for anyway I always wanted to go there
are you Chrissy my mother is dead I'm in
a place I swore I would never come back
to I I wouldn't have recognized you 40
years we'll do that do you I'd say yep
mixed
she's going to help us if we go to
lyrics miracles happen there he could
speak
[Music]
speak welcome to Lords
we're ready I'm not
[Music]
where did you leave leave I was banished
I leave
I loved you and you left uncle came home
can you ever forgive me
[Music]
you don't come to Lewis for a miracle
Island you come for the strength to go
on when there is no America
and there's always hope peace that's
what I hope for
[Music]
foreign
yeah
the only cookies
I don't know
[Music]
you know
um
[Music]
this is how I met my brothers
and how we became family
it's way bigger than basketball
it was us against everybody
people think they know my story
but this is how it all began a lot of
memories in this gym absolutely man how
we put banners up how we win ball games
what's crazy is the practices may have
went even harder that's what made the
game so easy bro
[Music]
family bomb
lifetime
we ended together we're going down are
we going up most of the time we're going
up
this is my story my story my story my
story this is our story
everybody is special in their own way
but then when you put us together we
like a superhero or we like Captain
Planet cuz we put them rings together
okay
[Music]